zach wheeler's on the mound he's
so good for the phillies he's been good
pretty much everywhere he's pitched and
this year's no difference jonathan india
he comes into this game betting 281 with
14 home runs and 49 rbis for cincinnati
who has designed working from the wind
up the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss and he
got a
first strikeout for zach wheeler and one
out here in the top of the first that's
a good start
tyler malley who on the road has been
sensational his composite numbers from
western and southern now he's just
coming off the wind molly has gave him
his ninth of the year and he's a good
guy to start this series although i
think that you know the temptation to
try to match your opponent sometimes can
be overwhelming especially when you face
a guy like zach wheeler
best advice for tyler malley here be the
best version of yourself don't worry
about the other guy you're pitching
against the phil's lineup not against
zach wheeler harper having a fine season
his powers peaked again of late five
homers in his last nine games
on base in 20 straight tied for the best
active run
and tyler o'malley strikes out the red
hot bryce harper joey bottom he's the
guy in this lineup for sure you just
don't want to beat it he's had 14 home
runs in his last 20 days
and he swings through that one and it's
a strikeout for zach wheeler so
round one to wheeler and it's his second
strikeout of the evening jonathan india
the lead-off hitter four the reds will
be the batter with two outs here in the
third
pitch
called third strike
i don't know what india was looking for
but that one was right down the middle
the third strikeout for
zach wheeler tonight and the final out
here in the top of the third here is
fellow pitcher zach wheeler
and he gets the call strike three
if we've learned anything first time
through
don't try to ride the edge in go off the
plate away you're gonna get the call
a little bit of a jam here in the fourth
well that'll bring up joey vado with
runners on first and second and nobody
out
vatto to deep right center field goal
wow
the greatness of joey votto
15 home runs in 22 games climb on his
back it's three nothing
reds
and another slider and he went down to
get a good one too on the outer part of
the plate down around the
[Laughter]
the knees tart pouty face
the only hit that maui's allowed a
single by jt real muto leading off the
second
payoff pitch to rio mucho here it is
swinging a miss struck him out with a
fastball right down the middle when he
blew it by real muto
mali with his fourth strike out of the
ball game
his third one two three inning in four
innings but winker was scratched with uh
lower back tightness right before the
game about 15 minutes before the game so
akiyama gets to start in center nakequin
moves over to left field
the o2 pitch
on the outside corner called third
strike
so wheeler
three pitches gets his fourth strikeout
shogo akiyama takes a seat and that'll
bring up the opposing pitcher
tyler malley
and then he puts one in play to reyes
spinning bare-handed play throw across
in time to get a wow what a play by
ronald torrez
as it uh as soon as it hit the grass you
knew it was going to spin but so did
ronald torres he grabbed it bare-handed
made the throw across the diamond panel
man what a play and india struck out
twice tonight three balls two strikes
two outs
the wind-up
pitch
swinging a miss and he got him
so it wasn't easy but zach wheeler able
to get through the reds lineup
one two three there in the fifth
andrew mccutchen stands in corey is
standing at second with nobody out india
hovers near the bag gregorius a huge
lead
swing and a miss
malley is money tonight that is five
maui strikeouts well that splitter that
he is throwing tonight it's just a
perfect combination for him and that
release point is spot on this is his
goldilocks knife nick castellanos
against the phillies 13 games hitting
nearly 360.
10 extra these hits 10 rbis
castellanos drills it
no doubter from nick castillanos
his second homer since coming back off
the injured list
and it gives the reds a four run lead in
philadelphia he gets a curve ball on the
inner part of the plate
he is the fourth red to 20 homers of the
season valley goes to work here
against a pinch hitter
and former red travis jankowski
swing at a miss another strikeout for
tyler malley
six
on the night yeah one of those nights
where that splitter is working to
perfection nobody on one man out back to
the top of the order in odouble herrera
grounded
suarez offline throw votto stays on the
bag
oh nice job by joey votto
to clean that up yeah the phillies are
checking the video out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh the ultimate heel
bryce harper set to lead things off here
in the bottom of the seventh
and he hits that one off the glove of
mali
picked up uh and over to first not in
time as mustachas bare hands it and
tries to make the play but harper doing
his best to get down the line he's safe
but first
that will be a base hit for bryce harper
bryce harper has reached base down 21
straight games and didi gregorius will
step to the plate out of the way hard
target he hits its sweeping swing into
this seven strikeouts
for it on point tyler malley
just a sensational
yep
eugenio suarez standing in oh for three
and this is belted down the left field
line and deep by suarez it is gone a two
run shot for au janio suarez that is his
23rd home run of the year
and the reds have opened up a six
nothing lead
one ball two strikes to bryce harper
swung on center field not deep breaking
in on it is akiyama and he is there to
make the catch and now thinks about
throwing back to first but
we are able to get back
in time joe girardi is coming out
have a conversation with ramon de jesus
did he get tossed
harper's still
having words oh so
oh we said we think joe and bryce maybe
got tossed bryce just went down into the
tunnel
didi gregorius will be the batter
leads off third in the 2-2 pitch swung
on line drive bear ball down the right
field line so girl will come in to score
dede's gonna round first head into
second
and he will stop there
and he's got a two out double and puts
the phillies on the board so the bills
avoid the shutout and this one's not
over yet
suarez
and the cincinnati reds take the opener
in philadelphia